DAMITH KARUNARATNE:
Hey, everyone.
Welcome to the session
on CI/CD anywhere.
In this session, we'll be
discussing why CI/CD anywhere
matters and how we're helping
customers streamline their
build, test, and deploy
processes across cloud
and on-premise environments.
My name is Damith Karunaratne,
and I'm a Senior Product
Manager at Google Cloud.
And this is my
colleague, Ben Houston,
who is a Kubernetes
Specialist at Google Cloud.
Today, we will be speaking to
you about Google's new approach
to doing CI/CD anywhere.
Before I dive into
product details,
I'd like to turn it over to Ben.
He's going to give
a quick overview
on why a hybrid
approach to CI/CD
is such a hot topic these days.
BEN HUSTON: Damith, thanks
for the great introduction.
And to those of you
in the audience,
I have an important
question for you.
Why should we care
about being able to do
continuous integration and
continuous delivery anywhere?
Well, we should care
because CI/CD flexibility
is an extremely important
topic right now.
This is due to the
fact that enterprises
need build processes that
can keep pace with constantly
changing business, regulatory,
and security requirements
and which will work across
multiple environments
they have made massive
investments in.
More specifically, enterprises
need transformational
development capabilities,
like build anywhere or deploy
anywhere, because these can
support massive on-demand
scaleup, are inherently
resilient and highly available,
can be authored and managed
in a completely versioned,
declarative manner, and
are instrumented with
out-of-the-box tooling
which provides end-to-end
observability across
the entire build system.
Unfortunately, most
enterprises are still
using flexible legacy
build tools like Jenkins,
which predate the cloud.
These tools simply can't meet
enterprise's current needs,
because they don't
provide a uniform way
to do continuous integration
or continuous delivery
across different environments.
And they also can't easily
scale to accommodate
the type of extremely high
volume, high concurrency
CI/CD that dominates modern
software development.
The good news is that most
of the performance problems,
which have traditionally
plagued build systems,
have been solved in recent
years by Kubernetes, which
is an extremely
popular orchestration
framework for operating
systems at massive scale.
The most highly
sought-after at-scale system
attributes, such as flexibility,
scalability, resilience,
control, and performance, are
now provided out of the box
by the Kubernetes API,
its unique approach
to distribute application
lifecycle management.
Next-gen build tools, like
the one that my colleague
Damith will introduce next,
understand they do not
need to reinvent the wheel.
These tools explicitly harness
the power of the Kubernetes API
and extend it with the rich,
new primitives specifically
designed to address the most
difficult CI/CD use cases.
Now, let me explain why
Kubernetes is such a big deal
for modern CI/CD.
Let me turn the
floor back to Damith
to introduce Google's new
approach to CI/CD anywhere.
DAMITH KARUNARATNE: Thanks, Ben.
With all of this in mind, I'd
like to introduce Cloud Build
Hybrid.
With Cloud Build
Hybrid, Google Cloud
is taking the power,
flexibility, and simplicity
of Google Cloud Build and
bringing it to anywhere
you can run Kubernetes.
Cloud Build Hybrid is powered
by Tekton, which means out
of the box, you
avoid vendor lock-in
and get the
reliability that you've
come to expect from Kubernetes.
Capabilities like self-healing
and graceful failover
allow for no single
point of failure.
Being able to run directly
on your infrastructure
behind your firewalls
now means you
can get the advantages
of cloud-native CI/CD
for workloads that can't
easily be moved to the cloud.
But Cloud Build
Hybrid is not only
about providing the benefits
of Kubernetes in Tekton.
Since this is an extension
of Google Cloud Build,
Cloud Build Hybrid provides
you a consistent interface
and workflow for building and
deploying your applications.
You can seamlessly switch
between using the fully managed
or hybrid version of
Cloud Build without having
to change your workflow.
You also get a
single pane of glass
through the existing
Cloud Build interface,
so you can easily
see activity across
all your CI/CD
environments in one place,
regardless of whether you're
using the fully managed
or hybrid version.
With Cloud Build's
developer-centric syntax,
you're able to easily
define your CI/CD workloads
without having advanced
knowledge of Kubernetes.
So developers can
spend more time
on building and
delivering software
that drives the business.
And upgrades have
never been easier.
All Cloud Build Hybrid instances
can be centrally managed,
which includes automated
updates and patches to make
sure you're always secure.
In addition to this, with the
Google-managed control plane,
you get the availability and
support your business relies on
to ensure smooth operation.
With Cloud Build Hybrid,
we handle the complexity
of multienvironment CI/CD.
Just add environment
configuration
to your Cloud Build
YAML, and your pipelines
will easily and
transparently run
the workload against registered
Kubernetes environments,
regardless of where
they're located.
Scaling these workloads
across your environment
is also simplified.
Cloud Build Hybrid harnesses
the power of Kubernetes
to provide robust
autoscaling and concurrency
for all your CI/CD processes.
Not only is scaling
simplified but it's
also more efficient
with resource pooling.
All workloads are entirely
containerized and managed using
Kubernetes, allowing them to
be scheduled right alongside
non-CI/CD workloads.
Workloads also run
completely hermetically,
ensuring that no build
time dependencies ever
cross-contaminate the runtime
dependencies relied upon
by other colocated workloads.
For hard-to-update,
resource-constrained,
on-premise environments
this scheduling fungibility
is extremely valuable.
Now, let's take a peek under
the hood to see how this works.
On the left, we have Google
Cloud in the fully managed
control plane.
On the right, we have a
hybrid multicloud environment
running a Kubernetes cluster.
With Google Cloud's
Connect service,
we can connect a Kubernetes
cluster to the Google Cloud
control plane.
Doing this will install
the Connect agent,
which will allow the
control plane to communicate
with the cluster.
Once the cluster
is connected, we
can enable the
Cloud Build feature
and install hybrid worker pools.
These hybrid worker
pools consist
of Tekton and some
additional components
and configuration that make
interacting with Google Cloud
seamless.
Once hybrid worker
pools are installed,
Cloud IAM will need to be
configured for Cloud Build
service accounts to
properly communicate
with the worker pool.
And finally, we'll
need to make sure
that the Kubernetes service
account on the worker pool
is configured to interact with
our source control and artifact
repositories.
Once Cloud Build
Hybrid is set up,
you can leverage the
same Cloud Build workflow
as the fully managed offering
to build, test, and deploy
your applications.
Your workload is
executed as a series
of build steps,
which are defined
as containers we call builders.
Since each build step is
hermetic and only exists
for the duration of
the step, any data
that you wish to
share across steps
can be shared through
a common workspace.
Google Cloud provides a set of
fully supported and maintained
builders for a
variety of workloads,
but there are also over a
hundred community builders
available.
You can also create
your own builder
to address unique use cases.
This workflow can
not only be used
to build containers but also
noncontainers, such as Java,
or Go artifacts, or
golden VM images.
The Cloud Build syntax
remains the same
for executing workloads
on hybrid worker pools.
All you need to do is specify
the hybrid pool that's
going to execute the workload.
For instance, in this
"Hello, world" example,
which has six lines of code,
we specify the hybrid pool
that the build is
going to run on.
This build will be transformed
into a Tekton task run
before it's sent to
the hybrid worker pool
with optional support for
Docker and Docker builds.
There's a large community
that uses Docker today,
and we want to make sure the
experience for the Docker
community is as
seamless as possible.
This means they
don't have to worry
about the overhead
of orchestrating
Docker and Docker build
processes in Kubernetes
since we take care of this
based on the hybrid pool
configuration.
The resulting Tekton
task run in this example,
which executes a
Docker and Docker build
ends up being 156 lines.
This translates to roughly
26 times more lines of code.
We're taking care of the
boilerplate and Kubernetes
configuration required to run
this build while integrating it
with Google Cloud Services, such
as Cloud IAM, Cloud Logging,
and source control integrations.
This allows developers to focus
on building great software
and not worry about the
underlying technologies running
their CI/CD workloads across
all their environments.
Cloud Build and
Cloud Build Hybrid
are part of a much broader
end-to-end GCP DevOps tool
chain.
Some of these
platforms and services
will be highlighted in the demo
that Ben is about to show you.
Ben, over to you.
BEN HUSTON: Thanks, Damith.
Awesome product overview.
I'm going to quickly walk
through the logical flow
of a short demo we've prepared.
First, we'll see a
developer check new code
into version control.
Next, we'll see Cloud Build
Hybrid detect the code change
and begin to kick off builds.
Then we'll see four
processes concurrently
building and deploying
the same application
to four different
target environments--
GKE, Anthos attached
clusters in AWS and Azure,
and an Anthos bare-metal cluster
which is running on premise.
Finally, we'll see the overall
build progress being monitored
with built-in tooling, like
the Cloud Operations suite
and Cloud Build dashboards.
OK, on onto the demo.
All right, you're now ready
for a quick demo of Cloud Build
Hybrid.
Here, we see four
different types
of Kubernetes clusters
registered with the Google
Cloud control plane--
GKE cluster, two Anthos-attached
clusters for EKS and AKS,
and Anthos bare-metal cluster
that is running on premise.
The great news is that
once you register a cluster
to Google Cloud,
installing Cloud Build
Hybrid it's dead simple.
Now we're going to open
a Cloud Shell session
and run a quick CLI command
to confirm that our cluster is
ready for action.
Yep, the install [INAUDIBLE]
is OK across the board.
OK, now that the environment
overview is out of the way,
let's quickly explain how Cloud
Build Hybrid jobs get queued.
Cloud Build Hybrid
uses a configuration
construct called the trigger
to associate a build event
like a pull request
with a build pipeline
and kick start
the build process.
You can see we have four
triggers to find, one for each
of our Kubernetes clusters.
In a moment, we're
going to switch
to an IDE, a.k.a., an
Interactive Development
Environment.
We'll commit a config change
and push it to our Git repo.
Afterwards, the
triggers we defined here
will listen for this
commit, and they kick off
a Cloud Build Hybrid job for
each of our environments.
In our IDE, we see
three important files--
cloudbuild.yaml,
deployment.yaml, and the Docker
file.
Cloudbuild.yaml defines
a build pipeline.
Here, you can see that
we've defined three steps--
Build Image, Push Image,
and Deploy to a Cluster.
Next, deployment.yaml contains
our Kubernetes deployment
configuration.
Here, we see that the Kubernetes
ServiceAccount, a Deployment,
and a HorizontalPodAutoscaler
have been defined.
Finally, the Docker
file shows what is
baked into our container image.
Here, we pull an
upstream nginx image,
write an awesome echo
statement, and then take a nap.
To show Cloud Build
Hybrid in action,
we're going to increase
the sleep to 11 seconds
and then commit and
push this change.
Now that code is committed,
we'll switch back
to the GCP console, where
we see four new builds
in this schedule.
Each build corresponds
to one of the triggers
we showed earlier--
one for Google Cloud, AWS,
Azures, and on premises.
Importantly, both the
CI and the CD steps
are happening at the same
time within each cluster
using Tekton.
Now that a few
minutes have passed,
we'll see that our builds
are starting to complete.
Next, we're going to click
on one of these builds
to see what that looks like.
Here, we can see
three build steps--
build, push, and deploy--
and our build logs.
You can also see metadata
related to the build.
For example, we can see that
it ran on hybrid worker pool
gke-cluster-001.
Finally, I want to show you
something else that's pretty
cool about Cloud Build Hybrid.
If you want to do a deep
analysis of your build logs,
these are already preintegrated
with Cloud Logging.
This means that
all of your build
logs are already defined with
the powerful Common Expression
Language.
You can modify as you
see fit and then use
to rerun your queries.
This allows you to easily
dive in and explore
any complex build errors
you might run into.
Now that our builds
are finished,
I want to show you one
more important thing.
When we explore the
build for another cloud,
like AWS, we see that
the build interface
looks identical to the
one we just saw for GKE,
which is totally awesome.
Now it's time to check the
stats of the workloads we just
deployed.
In the Google Cloud
console, we see a screen
that shows what workloads
existed in the default
Kubernetes namespace
of our clusters
before we committed new code.
Hitting Refresh shows we
now see four new nginx
apps running across
Google Cloud, AWS, Azure,
and on premise.
And just for fun,
let's confirm what
the dashboard for a few
other cloud providers shows.
Hitting refresh in EKS shows
the same workload deployed
about five minutes ago.
The view from the AKS dashboard
tells the exact same story.
Same workload again-- this
time, it's four minutes old.
And now we've reached
the end of our demo.
We've seen how
Cloud Build Hybrid
can be used to both
build and deploy apps
across multiple environments
using Tekton-powered Kubernetes
awesomeness and
slick Google tooling.
Enjoy.
DAMITH KARUNARATNE: Thanks
for the great demo, Ben.
To quickly recap,
you just saw Ben
show how Cloud Build Hybrid
provides a unified CI/CD
experience that abstracts
away the complexities
of cloud-native CI/CD with
Kubernetes while providing
the flexibility to build, test,
and deploy to any environment.
Google Cloud's fully
managed control planed
provides a single pane of
glass to gain visibility
into all your
workloads, regardless
of where they're running.
Finally, Cloud Build
Hybrid harnesses
the power of
Kubernetes and Tekton
to run your workloads
reliably at scale.
All of this will be
available in public preview
later this quarter.
In the meantime, to learn
more about Cloud Build,
take a look at the Cloud
Build documentation.
And don't forget
to check out some
of the other sessions on
Cloud Build, Cloud Deploy,
and securing your software
delivery pipeline.
Thanks for tuning in and
learning about Google Cloud's
approach to CI/CD anywhere.
Enjoy the rest of
Google Cloud Next.